Speaker 1: Let's go to Mike from
southeastern Pennsylvania. Mike, welcome.
Mike from southeastern
Pennsylvania, you're on the air.
And last chance for Mike from southeastern
Pennsylvania. By the way, I know people
start to think the tech problems are on my
end. They're not. I can see what's going
on. Like this is a user who has. This is a user
who's gone, actually. Okay. That's why I can't
hear them. They just hung up. Let's go next to
Dave from Windsor. Dave from Windsor, welcome.
Speaker 3: Oh, hi, Mr. Pacman. Welcome. I didn't
really have a question. Sometimes I listen to this
stuff, but I'm doing work. Congrats on the kid.
Speaker 1: All right. Dave from Windsor. Thank
you. I will put you back in the queue so you
can listen. What? Boy, what a fog. Some must
be a full moon, right? Not that I believe in that
type of thing. Let's go to Trenton from Detroit.
Trenton, welcome. Give us a question, sir.
Speaker 3: Oh, hey, David. So my question is,
I guess considering everything that's going
on with the January six committee, obviously
damning testimony. And yeah, I think
even yesterday, which is the testimony,
is probably some of the most damning since
Watergate. Do you think realistically it's
going to actually change anybody's mind about the
2022 primaries or the 2024 presidential election?
Because unfortunately, I don't think it will.
Speaker 1: I think it'll change some nominal
number of minds. I don't think it'll be a
game changer. However, if it leads to charges,
which I don't think it will, but if it led
to serious criminal charges against people,
I think it might. But just if it's just they
do the committee and then it's over and then
we have the November election and then that's it.
I think it will not do anything significant. No,
I think you're right.
Speaker 3:
You know, from from my end, I have a lot of people
that are kind of in that Trump MAGA land who I
guess I work with and with a lot of the other
stuff. They talk about it and deny it. With this,
it seems like they're not even tuned in, so I'm
not sure if that's a good sign for sanity or not.
Speaker 1: It's not a particularly good sign. I
mean, this is always a thing. The people who most
should be watching these hearings are just not
watching the hearings. That's it's a sad reality.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Now. All right.
Speaker 1: But listen, we've got
to vote. At least you'll vote, right?
Speaker 3: Oh, of course, everyone.
Speaker 1: Everyone must vote. All
right, Trent. And thank you for the call.
All right, Trenton, very, very good.